pensez-vous donc comme 88 % de vos
cadres que les Juifs aent trop de
pouvoir en France aujourd'hui c'est une
question à laquelle ils ont répondu là
encore massivement alors vous-même
comment vous réagissez à ça ça dépend
dans quel domaine que les Juifs aent
beaucoup de pouvoir dans la presse comme
les Bretons en non dans la marine et les
Corses dans les douanes ça ne me paraît
pas un peu discutable et que les gens du
Front national qui sont aperçus qu'un
certain nombre de de lobby juifs comme
celui
de de de Monsieur
can l'urait fait en quelque sorte une
persécution systématique ils ont
l'impression d'en voir beaucoup c'est
vrai